thank you all for coming today my name
is Maya Prabhu I'm a faculty member in
the School of Medicine and the division
of law and psychiatry and I am so
pleased to welcome you all here today on
behalf of my many co-organizers
including Dean Ratliff who's up here
with me who is a colleague of mine from
the center for international sustainable
development law and who's also a former
director of the Commission and
environmental cooperation and also me
Raj Desai who will be taking selfies
with a crowd later and who is also a
member of the department of psychiatry
and the School of Public Health I as I
said earlier I'm so heartened by the
number of people who are interested and
curious about the nexus between
migration and climate and what better
time dare I say for such an event in the
past few years since the signing of the
Paris Accord we have seen thousand-year
rainstorms occurring by the dozens we've
seen a massive coral bleaching incident
that has affected 70% of the world's
coral reefs we've seen disastrous fires
on every continent and of course just
this week we've had the publication of
the most recent IPCC report which should
instill a greater sense of urgency and
alarm in us than ever before but I fear
has not yet penetrated the consciousness
of those who would be most important to
read it before I walk you for the day
and tell you a little bit about what
you're going to hear today and who
you're going to hear from please let me
thank a number of persons who made this
event possible
first and foremost please let me thank
the Macmillan Center for its incredibly
generous support in a variety of ways as
well as the Edward and Dorothy Clarke
Kemp Fund the Yale program and refugees
forced displacement and humanitarian
responses the asian-american cultural
center of the Ola and psychiatry
division the Department of Mental Health
and Addiction Services which is very
interested in this issue of how to
respond and thinking about planetary
health and how to have systems respond
and the vice president's office which
provided support from the Woodward
lectureship and as I hope you many of
you will be able to attend tomorrow we
also had the benefit of tremendous
intellectual contributions from a number
of climate scientists based in Asheville
North Carolina and
technical pre-conference that we had and
they'll talk to me more about it but I
would like to also give a special nod
and thanks to case consultants to the
North Carolina Institute for climate
studies in North Carolina State
University and many people from the NOAA
staff and some of them are here today
and they'll be very happy to talk to you
about data and science amongst other
things so today we have assembled a very
broad cross-section of experts from
multiple disciplines and multiple social
economic and cultural backgrounds and we
needed we thought such a broad coalition
to tackle issues or this issue which is
truly interdisciplinary let me tell you
a little bit about the questions for the
day in our very first panel we have
several people with Mayumi Myesha alum
Erica Bower list of harpeia who are
going to ask some fundamental questions
what do we mean by climate migration
what are the causes of human mobility
what - how does climate change and
climate factors or weather events
influence the push and pull of persons
and who is most disproportionately
affected by the factors that cause
people to move we'll be thinking about
human security we'll be thinking about
political instability as well in our
second session after lunch Michael crook
Kanta Kumari Rigaud from the World Bank
Jessy roubo will allow us to stay I'm
going to say evidence driven and data
based and try to think about the future
what do data and evidence tell us about
the questions for planning if climate
models are as good as they have ever
been
why is climate understanding and
consensus so low and what can all of us
do to better communicate as Mike says
the good the bad and the ugly about
science
what has the World Bank learned about
what site types of questions need to be
asked as part of development finance
decision-making what does it mean to be
financially supportive of climate
resilience in our last panel of the day
we wanted to turn home and look at
what's happening both here in
Connecticut and in the United States as
a connecticut as you know is a receiving
state from many persons who are affected
by Hurricane Maria and it also will
require us to think deeply about issues
of internal displacement even though we
tend to think of these things
happening far away we're going to ask
questions about what does law and policy
what can law and policy tell us to help
prepare systems for the displaced
communities and how can we support
cities to ensure that all communities
are better prepared above all having
spoken on refugees and displaced persons
in the past we do not want to leave you
in the depths of despair about the state
of the climate or the state of
populations really this day is intended
to galvanize all of you to think about
how you can be an advocate in your
personal community's academic
communities local communities to
innovate and advocate where you are and
help you and the people you work with to
find your own path to climate resilience
Commissioner clay I cannot wait to hear
what you have to say about state
initiatives in the absence of leadership
elsewhere in the afternoon my very good
Canadian colleague is going to be a is
going to be speaking about openings left
by the adoption of the Paris Accord
agreement and of course many of you are
here to see the wonderful and notte tong
who will encourage you to be bold and
brave so we'll talk more about him in a
minute
Dane I know you wanted to ask some more
questions oh yeah well thank you and
actually maybe just try to frame to the
things that we'll be talking about on a
few other issues that you touched on
today's conference isn't about climate
change per se but as Maya alluded to a
complex set of issues and problems that
are interrelated and which solutions
aren't the purview of any single
discipline rather these are issues that
require various disciplines and actors
involved to work together among states
non States regions peoples developed in
developing countries to break down their
their silos and work together toward
what the UN Framework Convention on
Climate Change terms the common concern
of humanity we're really talking about
the limits of adaptation here today and
climate induced migration and
displacement is difficult to define it's
usually never the proximate or sole
cause for migration
it's difficult to assess and it's even
more difficult still to proactively
prevent and address it before it happens
rather than through piecemeal reactive
actions post some natural disaster one
issue is that it seems we may not have
had the same the same epistemological
basis for assessing this problem but now
it's a it's clear that we are
approaching a common set of facts to
understand these challenges and the
latest IPCC report that Maya talked
represents really the best scientific
knowledge we've ever had and yet in
spite of that we still can't agree yes
exactly and so what we what we also know
is that climate change increases the
intensity of so-called sudden onset
events hurricanes fires and floods and
slow onset events such as droughts
glacial retreat desertification and
sea-level rise and in the case of both
types of climate events any of them can
exacerbate already existing
socio-political conflict potentials and
lead to a tipping point whereby people
become displaced or choose to migrate as
a last resort or plan migration as a
choice of adaptation another problem is
that climate change makes it harder for
those who are already displaced to
return to their homes especially where
their capacity to adapt is low or the
limits tapped ation have been reached
and at a prelude event to this one that
Maya discussed earlier held in Asheville
this year we heard a story from a UN
High Commissioner for Refugees
representative about a Somali farmer who
said drought made the conflict worse
some Raiders came and took away the
little food we had raised on our farm
now we're in a very hard time the people
at home faced conflict and famine
they're starving even if we could go
back we would only have dry land and
death to greet us and such stories are
becoming all too common and increasingly
so luckily we in the international
climate process we're seeing convergence
around
adaptive capacity in the most vulnerable
countries we have a huge chasm between
the adaptive capacity of wealthy Western
countries and the most vulnerable
countries and I think this is going to
be one of the the biggest questions that
the international climate community is
going to have to tackle and face
inability to adapt can often be a
function of bad planning and policy and
coherence or a lack of governance
structures for example providing for
food and water security creating
resilient infrastructure and the
presence of relief for migrants
determines how quickly they can return
and policymakers in developed countries
with high adaptive capacities should
really be on notice about the need to
scale up the quality of a migrants
ability to contribute economically and
participate in a new society they should
provide legal protections and remedies
provide aid and assistance to increase
this adaptive capacity in these most
vulnerable countries wherever possible
luckily interdisciplinary work is well
underway in a number of international
organizations fora and NGOs to consider
and address these problems some of these
are the Task Force on displacement under
the Warsaw mechanism for loss and damage
in the Paris agreement process something
we'll hear a little bit about later
perhaps negotiation of a global compact
on migration the International
Organization for Migration UN High
Commissioner for Refugees etc all of
these are working on this problem of the
large and growing chasm between high
adaptive capacity and the lack of it and
indeed this issue really is the common
concern of humanity where every field of
human knowledge is being called to arms
to address it and that's what we're
hopefully here to talk about today yes
that's awesome I've had you introduce
yourselves and so we've actually alluded
twice now time in Turkey are you sitting
in the front there who'll be speaking
about the Paris Accord and I've also
asked him to provide also a non North
American perspective on the Paris Accord
and the ambitions within alright so one
housekeeping matter in order to
facilitate the questions with president
Tong we're going
take them in a basket that they're up
there please write them down and we will
and put them up there and try to get
them to us by about 10:30 and beyond
that welcome and thank you I'd like to
turn the mic over to Melissa Goodell who
has been a incredible supporter of this
project she is the associate director of
the Yale Office of Sustainability and
like us truly appreciates the goal of
transformative change thank you thank
you good morning I will just speak very
very briefly I'm not on the program I am
here as a support person for this team
because this is an extraordinary event
here that you here at Yale I'm going to
sidetrack for just one moment to tell
you a little history lesson ten years
ago in 2008 Yale hosted the conference
of governor's on climate change at the
time the the occasion was that it was
the 100th anniversary of the conference
of Governors which had originally
started with Theodore Roosevelt and a
guy named Gifford Pinchot who started
the National Forest Service but also the
Yale School of Forestry and
environmental studies so we felt that we
had an imperative to do this and it
would be a really good idea to invite
all 50 governors to come to Yale which
was definitely life changing for those
of us who organized it and the outcome
was phenomenal because at the time this
is gonna sound very familiar we were
really seriously lacking in federal
leadership on climate action and the
governor's got together and wrote a
declaration to the federal government
saying please whatever you do don't
supersede what we are doing we are in a
position to be proactive and it was
fairly effective actually Bush just sort
of looked the other way and let the
states keep going they didn't overrule
things like emission standards for cars
etc and it was really quite effective at
the time rob CLE was just fresh out of
getting three degrees here at Yale
University he has a master's degree from
FES a JD from the law school and a PhD
from FES and he decided to give us a
break for a little bit but then came
back to Connecticut and joined our team
our our community I should say not our
team and he has been a remarkable force
for innovation and pro action in the
State Department of Energy and
Environmental Protection with his vision
and guidance Connecticut was one of the
first states to step up and say we are
still in we have a GHG reduction
commitment in the state of Connecticut
of 50 percent sorry 80 percent by 2050
I always flip those and we were one of
the first to do that we have been
extremely progressive on climate change
and when I speak to colleagues abroad
because of Rob and his team and the
tremendous work that they've done I'm
able to hold my head up and say yes I
know what's happening in Washington DC
is a little bit weird and criminal
however what we're doing here in
Connecticut is really going to make a
difference and so I ask you to join me
in welcoming Commissioner clay thank you
so much Melissa for that introduction
and history lesson always appreciate
coming back to a place where I've spent
a lot of time here at Yale and are you
recruiting me to be back on your team I
don't know I've it's a nice team here
and really thank you all for being here
and Maya for inviting me and for
assembling this this real amazing
assembly of diverse people and
backgrounds and experiences which is the
climate change challenge in a nutshell
that you need all of those folks working
together across so many disciplines and
have that be part of so many
conversations where it may not be
happening enough today and that's what
you're going to talk about over the next
two days and particularly focus on
climate change and climate refugees and
this is obviously a global phenomena and
that's going to be a lot of your next
two days but it has already had local
impacts here in Connecticut and across
the United States from Katrina to Maria
to Florence
Michael listen Ames is getting way too
long climate change is causing
disruption and migration within the US
and
territories and the most vulnerable
among us here in the United States are
environmental justice communities are
persons of color the poor the young the
old they're all the most likely to live
in flood prone areas the most likely to
be in those places where sea level rise
is going to be impacting them they're
the most vulnerable to heat waves and
droughts and those other things that do
actually happen even here in Connecticut
they're most likely to be forced out of
their homes by floodwaters for example
Tropical Storm Irene now there's a blast
from the past 2011 which seems literally
a lifetime ago
our substation a critical substation in
Bridgeport Connecticut just 20 minutes
down the road that is as many of you
here in Connecticut know that is one of
our our low to moderate income distress
communities here in Connecticut a
substation they're serving those hundred
thousand people in Bridgeport came
within inches of being flooded and being
out of power for over two months so that
is the the edge on which we live here in
even in Connecticut on terms of
resiliency and climate change that would
have dramatic effects in our communities
in our cities here in Connecticut we're
also on the receiving end of climate
refugees here in Connecticut
particularly from Puerto Rico and post
Maria and I was just talking with local
legislators from Waterbury yesterday and
it is having a material effect on their
communities it is changing the nature of
who is where in their in their
communities and that is a direct effect
of climate refugees happening here in
Connecticut so you're going to explore
those issues in depth from local
perspectives global perspectives for the
next two days and this is an important
conversation more so now than ever
because there are some at the highest
levels of our federal government who are
rejecting the science of climate change
they're ignoring the impacts that
they're seeing right before their eyes I
want to rest to you the rest assure that
here in Connecticut we do not ignore
this we listen to scientists I am a
scientist that is I'm actually the first
scientist to lead our agency it's
something I get a lot of street cred for
particularly my geology background which
folks in my agency are really proud of
we listen to our scientists and Nicole
I know that seems surprising but that's
what we do here in Connecticut and we
understand the science and it does guide
our actions I'm not gonna spend my next
sort of ten minutes bashing the Trump
administration I do that plenty of other
times in other places that's actually
what my Twitter feed is for you can go
follow me at Commissioner Rob I think
that is the main purpose of Twitter's to
have those sort it's hard to call those
conversations but in the absence of
federal leadership and with the dire
predictions of this very week coming
from the UN's Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change it's incumbent on local
and state governments particularly here
in the United States to fill the gap
we're seeing at the federal level my
goal here is to stay positive
well mostly positive and focuses on what
is working at the local level and
regional level I'm gonna do my best to
ignore at least for a morning what's
happening in Washington it's good to do
that on occasion and sort of disconnect
from what's going on down there and you
have come to a state for those who are
not from Connecticut that is setting an
example that other states are following
and addressing the most pressing problem
environment energy problem of our time
so after the over the last eight years
and Melissa alluded to this we've been
actually putting things into action
we've deployed hundreds of megawatts of
clean energy here in Connecticut we've
created innovative financing programs
that first-in-the-nation Connecticut
Green Bank to deploy renewables and
efficiency at scale here in Connecticut
and we've seen an investment of over a
billion dollars in our clean energy
economy right here in Connecticut and
that's tens of thousands of clean energy
jobs here in Connecticut at a time when
we've been challenged in terms of job
growth this past legislative session had
two transformative pieces of legislation
that will actually set us up well for
the next decade here in Connecticut on
our ability to address climate change
and have a clean energy future and I
want to know that here in Connecticut
those who are passed with overwhelming
bipartisan majorities literally thirty
four to two because we count those sort
of Beau's 34 to two in our Senate and
120 to 130 to 10 in our General Assembly
that's very different here in
Connecticut than what you see in
Washington because
rasaan climate the environment and clean
energy is not a partisan issue in
Connecticut and that's actually very
refreshing
and why I like working in a place like
Connecticut instead of down in
Washington so for those who are
interested this gets technical Public
Act 1882 we set an interim target to
reduce our economy why greenhouse gas
emissions
forty five percent by 2030 that was
recommended by our Governor's Council on
climate change we basically looked where
we are now and then Melissa we looked at
that 80% by 2050 goal you draw a
straight line so I may argue it
should've been more curved and what
about we least you have a straight line
and where we have to go by 2030 is 45%
economy-wide reductions which by the way
means you have to electrify everything
and clean your grid to a substantially
clean level by 2030 this complements our
existing on the books 80% by 2050 target
now we can debate about whether that's
enough at particularly because of the
IPCC report that was based on the 2
degree warming scenario and not a degree
and a half but we have to have yes
ambitious significant action on the
books it's a target it is not a goal
actually in Connecticut statutes to get
us on track to where we have to be by
2030 to make sure we are achieving our
2050 goals that's 12 years that's where
our focus is now for the next decade is
achieving that economy why greenhouse
gas coal we also in that same bill
required all future state projects that
are located in our coastal zone to take
into account that we are facing up to 20
inches or 50 centimetres of sea-level
rise on our coast by 2050 20 or 50 by
2050 we should let that sink in in a
moment but we are if we are putting
state or federal money into
infrastructure which the state does and
our infrastructure last a long time and
now needs to add two feet of free board
above existing flood elevations to
account for what we know is already
baked into the system in terms of sea
level rise and that is a significant
amount of change in a very short amount
of time and unfortunately the Northeast
happens to be one of those places around
the globe where we will experience more
sea level rise than most other places
around the globe
and I'm the break you can there's some
fun sort of Geoscience and the Gulf
Stream currents that of why that's the
case we also passed public Act 18 - 50
that's increasing our renewable
portfolio standard to 40% class 1
renewable so wind and solar by 2030
which when you combine that with the
nuclear power and large-scale hydropower
means we're gonna have a 65 to 75
percent clean grid by 2030 and that's
essential that the clean grid when
you're electrifying transportation in
your building heating to make sure that
those electrons are as clean as possible
when they're powering our cars and homes
we also continued our efforts to deploy
rooftop solar and solar on our
businesses and we created a statewide
shared clean energy program targeting in
particular low and moderate-income
customers to make sure that they're part
of this clean energy revolution as well
last month in San Francisco at the
global climate action summit we joined
the powering pascoal Alliance our last
coal-fired power plant in Connecticut
will stop running by 2021 we also
committed to face out super pollutant
HFCS and refrigeration on transportation
we for those of you who are here in
Connecticut we actually built two mass
transit systems in the last eight years
a dedicated bus way that has seen
ridership they weren't anticipating til
2030 already today and a New Haven
Hartford Springfield rail line again for
someone who's grown up and lived in
Connecticut these are transformative
transportation choices which means that
you don't have to have a car if you want
to go to work or to school and that is
good for for us here in Connecticut from
a mission standpoint from a local
emission stand for but it's also good
for the planet if you want need to own a
car we have our first we are the first
state in the nation to be range
confident we have enough public vehicle
charging stations spread around our
we're not a very large state but they're
spread strategically that you can go
anywhere you're no more than twenty
minutes from a charging station we have
our very successful rebate program the
cheaper program which stands for
Connecticut hydrogen electric automobile
purchase rebate program but we like
cheaper which is an on the hood rebate
when you buy that electric vehicle and
we've sold over three thousand
last month we sold 230 we're seeing now
trigger the Tesla Model 3 s the
exponential growth in electric vehicle
sales so I've just covered a few of the
policy implementation and innovations
that are happening in Connecticut and I
know my time is limited here but I want
to be recognized for a moment for those
of you who are not from Connecticut
we're not a very large state we often
need we're about the third we're the
third smallest in the country some of
you may be from cities or counties that
are larger than Connecticut but we punch
above our weight class and we do that
often with partnerships and we partner
with states throughout this region one
example of that is our Regional
Greenhouse Gas Initiative Connecticut is
part of the founding member one of the
first it is the first cap-and-trade
system
market-based mechanism that put a price
on carbon from the electric sector where
we saw 50 percent reductions in
emissions while our per capita GDP grew
faster than the national average so it
breaks that myth that you can't that
you're gonna do this you're gonna crash
the economy no it actually our economies
grew faster than the nation we that
cap-and-trade system allowed our state's
our eight states to invest over two
billion dollars in clean energy and
efficiency here in Connecticut and
throughout the Northeast and into the
mid-atlantic and now New Jersey and
Virginia are looking to be a part of
that as well and the other collaboration
worth mentioning and Melissa mentioned
it we are part of the we're still in the
u.s. climate alliance when Trump
announced his decision to withdraw from
Paris it was not a surprise it was still
disappointing but 17 states was
Democratic and Republican governor
stepped in and stepped up and said we're
actually going to follow the scientists
and commit our communities our state's
to the planet that we're still in and
that 17 state alliance represents nine
trillion dollars in economic activity
it's the third largest country in the
world so this is not an incident
California and New York helped you know
that Connecticut is not all of that um
we're actually a very small slice of
that but it is what is hopefully part of
should hopefully inspire it inspires us
to move forward and California is that
that tip of the spear that we're all
trying to keep up with although we
occasionally do some things that I think
forced them to go a little deeper in
their emissions and their commitments
when I want to stay positive and hopeful
I often turn to President Obama I'm
having trouble finding Trump quotes that
I could weave into my speeches so I have
to go back to Obama and in his farewell
addressed and this one is particularly
relevant to this conference he when he
was talking to the nation as a whole he
said without bolder action our children
won't have time to debate the existence
of climate change they'll be busy
dealing with its effects the
environmental disasters economic
disruptions and waves of climate
refugees seeking sanctuary now we can
and should argue about the best approach
to the problem but to simply deny the
problem not only betrays future
generations it betrays the essential
spirit of innovation and practical
problem-solving that guided our founders
I do know that quote was from 2016 it's
a little out of date because the it's
not our kids that are dealing with the
disasters the economic stress ruction
and the climate refugees it's us and
it's it's now but putting that aside the
main message of is of innovation problem
solving and that's the core of frankly
what America does best or at least used
to do best and state and local and
regional governments have long been and
will continue to be those innovators in
the policy space we don't have to look
so far back in history to I'll quote
another president because I'm in the
sort of mode this morning President
Kennedy who was announcing that we
should go to the moon in his famous
speech at Rice University said we choose
to go to the moon in this decade and do
the other things not because they are
easy but because they are hard because
that goal will serve to organize and
measure the best of our energies and
skills because that challenge is one
that we are willing to accept one that
we are unwilling to postpone and one
which we intend to win and the others
too so those are the types of things I
think we need at this moment that type
of galvanizing spirit that singular
mission the moonshot that one thing is
to get to Net Zero Carbon to get our
plan
it in a place where we are able to save
it to galvanize the political will the
technical understanding the innovation
to make that possible make that happen
it's going to be hard there will be
setbacks these are not easy things but
it is the only thing we can do for the
sake of future generation so I hope part
of this conference gets you excited and
energized about those things that you
can do in each of your spheres of
influence to make that possible and I
hope that you look to the political will
of the not the federal government at
this moment in time but look at
Connecticut and California and New York
and Massachusetts and Maryland and
Washington State Oregon Jersey Vermont
those are the places to look for the
innovation the examples of folks who are
doing everything that they can at this
moment in time in particular and that to
me is encouraging and it is essential
and that sort of commitment to real
action which we have here in Connecticut
in those other states I believe is
contagious so thank you so much for
having this well I'm happy to take
questions - there's quick ones
it is it is possible our scenarios have
been based on our 80% by 2050 goal we
would have to be a little more ambitious
particularly in that 2030 to 2050 10
trying frame there and what is always
fascinating about these the sort
projections we did we went through a
modeling exercise it always looks at
what you have now I mean your ability to
scale up all the things that you have in
your current portfolio and it is doable
with electrification of vehicles now
that would be by 2030 hundreds of
thousands of electric vehicles on the
road when we now have 5000 so tremendous
increases there and by 2050 you're only
selling zero emission particularly light
duty vehicles the heavy duties get a
little more complicated you need to find
some other solutions there
electrification of homes you need to
turn about although we're we're we're
modeling about 11,000 or so
homes per year transitioned from in
Connecticut's oil or natural gas to air
source heat pumps ground-source heat
pumps that's level of turnover of our
the thing in your basement which most
people don't want to think about most of
the time is not nearly as sexy as a
Tesla which I think more people will be
more likely to buy electric vehicles
because they are frankly the best and
coolest and most fun things out there
your furnace is never that finding the
best one where we're concerned about now
in the near term you can if you have
those big three wedges vehicles home
heating and cooling or business while
meeting cooling and your grid if you're
falling on one you can press the
accelerator on another and make up for
it in the near term by 2050 they all
have to be basically zero carbon they
all have to do that and frankly the IPCC
report and others recognize that there
will also be a need to probably pull out
of the atmosphere to do things
the either through a forest station
reforestation draw more carbon out of
the atmosphere because many of those
curves get above and beyond where we
should be and require that pulling back
to actually achieve a sustainable level
whether those hit tipping points and and
other things those are there is a lot of
risk involved in will just go over the
line for a while and we'll figure out a
way to bring it back under the line is
is another question in Connecticut
though and we often some folks say well
why did you care Connecticut you're the
slice of a slice of a slice you're um
but what we're mostly focused on is the
innovations in the policy space that
could be translatable and transferable
and we're going to keep doing that
because you get things like our regional
greenhouse gases issue
you know Regional Greenhouse Gas
Initiative 50% reductions from the power
sector in a matter of ten years so that
type of it is possible to do and it's
those types of examples particularly in
the near term and I'm trying to focus
mostly on the next twelve years because
those are our critical is we can't do
that we definitely are screwed for 2015
and that's the technical term screwed
I'm the Commissioner is allowed to say
those those sorts of things one more
right there
so the question of the local regional
science needs one of the things that
we've done is partner with UConn our our
state university on that understanding
of our localized sea level rise risk so
that's been an area which we're gonna
keep updating year over year but that's
been an area we've really taken the
science and said in statute do whatever
the scientists tell you is the plan for
whatever the sciences tell you about sea
level rise in Connecticut I'm sure there
are probably other good examples of that
type of thing and we are actually a
state where you can pass that into law
which is amazing to think of that in
state law the it literally references
the scientists who will come up with
that number that you have to plan to and
then build your buildings to and
incorporate that level of sea level rise
um if you have ideas come see me
afterwards gov places that we can bring
that best science to our to our local
policy and I will wrap it up there but
hopefully we'll have time for a very
short break before our keynote we have a
panel that I'd very much like to get to
now so commissioner thank you very much
for coming today
[Applause]
[Music]
you